seeking justice a lot of people get this
really confused with forgiveness they're
like but if you forgive why do you still
want consequences for them i don't know
maybe because i want them to stop
hey everybody welcome to led live why is
it whenever we have
systematic abuse in faith-based
communities we always get it wrong
find out on this episode of led live
light
exposing darkness welcome back to led
live everybody
today's topic is gonna be a very
interesting one and i'm so glad we have
a couple of guests who have been
not the first time on our show you guys
have been on our show before it maybe
looked a little bit different on our
background but
thank you nicole and sarah for coming on
and dealing with this very
intricate and detailed topic that is a
difficult one to talk about
but needs to be talked about so if you
guys haven't noticed from the
um the thumbnail we're gonna discuss
ravi zacharias and some of the details
that we're surrounding around that but
i think that there's a deeper deeper
implication
to that that i think we all need to be
aware of and
we're going to get to the bottom of that
so thank you guys for coming on board
and uh you know maybe you guys can tell
us a little bit about
some of the ministries that you're
involved in and um you know why you're
even here in the first place
well sarah and i both work together on
bucket brigade against abuse
which we have a website
bucketbrigadeagainstabuse.com where
people
specifically within the seventh-day
adventist faith community can report
allegations of sexual abuse or assault
and then we help them
coach them through the process of how to
report those to the church or law
enforcement
or wherever it needs to go and
then i'm working with project safe
church with the lake union where we've
both
done a lot of trainings up there
teaching people how to
respond to abuse in the northern region
what we call the lake union of the
seventh-day adventist church
and then i don't know i'm writing a
series of books called the tales of the
exodus
she's super modest about that they're a
best-selling series on amazon
and they are the single series
of children's books that i recommend to
those who have been through trauma
everywhere so keep going yeah i'm
writing them
don't undersell it i'm writing them to
help
people understand how a god of love
allows suffering
how he works out his will and
his purpose in the midst of things that
often are not his will
and so it's the story of the children of
joshua and caleb as they're experiencing
slavery
and trauma in the exodus story and how
god delivers them how god works through
everything even stuff that's not his
will
so anyway yeah and it's designed for
younger a younger audience right right
um
my kids i've read them with my kids
before my kids are eight and ten
and and they appreciated the the the
stories and
you know i as detailed as they were it
was really neat for them to
to kind of get a glimpse of what it was
like to experience that i mean the the
israelites experienced some severe
abuse yes and i really want people to
understand the bible does deal with
trauma
and how to process it even on a child's
level because it's in story form but i
find a lot of teenagers and adults even
old people are writing to me saying
these books have unlocked for me
how to process my own trauma so i'm just
writing it because this is the gospel
in the old testament how god balances
justice and mercy and i think
that's one of the main issues that we
face in dealing with abuse situations
all the time people think love is soft
fluffy stuff
and then they look at the god of the old
testament they're like why is god so
mean
in the old testament jesus is so nice
and so loving
they need to see the god of the old
testament the god of the new testament
both balance
justice and mercy perfectly in every
situation the problem is we misdefine
love
yeah yeah so this is this is barely
happening
in any church right right right and
everybody's
estimation so nicole and i have worked
together for
a long time and a number of different
types of things like she talked about
and i also
have an organization called wilderness
to wild
and it is specifically for meeting the
needs
of trauma and abuse recovery for women
within the faith community so we have
giveaways a lot of free resources on our
website we have a
whole new free resource page in spanish
language that we are continuing to build
and grow so if you go to our website
you will see the espanol section you can
get those for free
and we also have books including
one that nicole and i co-authored with a
friend of ours and
we do coaching podcasts we aren't quite
as fancy as you guys here we're a little
bit more like sit down in my living room
and have a cup of coffee together
um but we have um
a lot of resources as well as post
trauma wellness
and um and online courses for
guiding out of the wilderness of feeling
like you're in that trauma fog into the
wild which is
where you completely understand the idea
of god's identity for you
so with wild we just call it wild for
short
i do a lot of work with writing and
speaking
and abuse recovery coaching
and just educating and
creating awareness and creating tools
and resources
for a couple of audiences one for those
who've actually experienced it
and need healing and two for church
leaders who
are seeking to make their churches safer
places
for the vulnerable instead of falling
into the trap
of the stuff that of getting it wrong
like when
crisis hits your church how do you
see through all of the slate of hand or
the slate of mind that's going on
there's actually a great book about that
called slates of mind
um about the mental tricks
and the magic tricks that abusers use
to groom
and to calculatedly cultivate trust
for themselves so that other people will
flock to their defense
against the abuse victim and that right
there
in a nutshell is part of why churches
get it wrong so often which is what
we're here to talk about
well i'm you know i'm not easily shocked
these days
i've kind of had a a ministry experience
of 10 years of
of looking at sort of these very
disturbing and evil things that are
happening
in the world and uh i was completely
caught off guard with this
and i can remember the first time that
that somebody brought it up that
ravi was abusing women and i was like
whatever you know like this guy's
this this this guy's probably got so
many people just wanting his money
that's that was my initial thought
and then when the stuff started really
uncovering and coming out and then it's
like story after story you started
hearing these stories of the abusers and
what was actually transpiring
i mean i was just like like oh my
goodness i ca i can't believe this but
i'm sure you
you ladies are not shocked by this no we
were just getting the pushback
from all the people who were like no
you are evil why would you think this
of someone on such a high pedestal
and so we were getting like that vitriol
when we were saying hey guys
something isn't right here there are
people being harmed behind the scenes
here
and then there's this outpour of boiling
lava from over the castle walls you know
and usually this is what we experience
and you know honestly every time i hear
an allegation
i know okay when the allegation comes
out 95
chance it's true because statistically
when someone comes forward with an
allegation of sexual abuse or assault 92
to 98
of the time it's true but there is that
five percent and i always have to keep
that five percent
in my mind knowing this could be
something that
is abuse of the person instead of the 95
chance that he abused someone else
because i think false allegations
genuine intentional false allegations
are their own form of sexual abuse
it causes tremendous trauma to a person
who's falsely accused so you always have
to keep that five percent in mind
but on this one from the moment the
first person came forward i remember
talking with a friend of mine who was
pastor and
he and i were turning it over in our
minds he's going but but his sermons but
i love
hearing him but look at all these things
and i'm like
yeah but this woman doesn't seem to be
making it up
and she's got credible evidence so we
just we both left it as
we'll have to see what happens because
that's often what i have to do
i can't just take a hard line you're
wrong if you
you know i have to just say well i can't
persuade people but of course in this
situation
eventually once there was an
investigation everything came out and
that's what usually makes the difference
if there's an investigation you can find
out especially in this day and age
a person who is doing the kinds of
things that he was doing on the side
leaves a trail in technology it's hard
to believe
that people around him did not see the
signs
when you have this many things coming
forward and we're not talking a few
women here we're talking
when the details came out hundreds
of people he was corresponding with
that's that's incredible well the guy's
got four cell phones
come on is he are you are you a drug
dealer like you know like people
of course a lot of people need prayer
yeah right yeah and they all have a
personal access line to me
um but you know when someone is
traveling in a private jet with our
personal masseuse
um who's imported from another country
and then we're talking
i mean some of the things i've read of
course i'm not an i'm not an attorney
and i can't comment with like legal
certainty on these
but the the things that have been
reported made it look like
there was a somebody was processing
visas
for women from third world countries to
come
and be here and then everyone's like
well if this
was so bad why didn't those women say
anything well i don't know
maybe because this is the company that
provided their visa
that that maybe they've been threatened
maybe they have people at home that
they're sending money back to that are
going to starve without them
maybe their family at home has been
threatened you know what are you gonna
do
in a foreign country you may not speak
the language well or you might have
learned
and you are completely alone here and
this is you are the power differential
it's not just like oh you know a little
bit it's like
massive power differential so you're
completely dependent
on that so yes how did people not see it
well
somebody had to be processing fraudulent
visas
somebody had to be noting that there
were people coming in
with wonky immigration stuff and
and then being kept here and being paid
under the table
i mean there's gonna be things there's
gonna be something going on there
you know somebody's turning a blind eye
too or
you know sometimes the victims like you
were saying about visa and also you know
other countries something like that
uh sometimes they think it is it's
normal yeah it's like oh i think
it's normal or something like that
that's right in many countries
where you know where males are given the
power culturally the more that there's a
cultural expectation that a man
has control and ought to have control
the more the way is paved for abuse
if you can give an abuser a sense of
entitlement he can do anything
because all that matters is whether he
can find a way to justify it
once you believe that you have a right
to be over
this woman these children in your family
for example and god has given you power
okay so you rape somebody a little bit
now and then
you molest your children a little bit
now and then but you know god has put
you in this position of power
you can rationalize anything if you
believe that god has placed you over
other people
and i think that's part of what happened
with ravi and with his enablers
that he believed that god had placed him
in this position this is how abusers
typically work
they rationalize you know let's say
you're random guy who preaches
and spends a whole day in ministry and
that night he's just wiped out and he
feels like
man i deserve a break i worked so hard
for god
he falls let's say he binges on porn
then he feels rotten
and all during the week he beats himself
up but then by thursday he's pulling
himself together because he knows he's
got to preach this weekend then he
preaches
and he gives this powerful appeal and
people come forward weeping
yeah now he's like you've just
short-circuited the whole process of
repentance because
why should he repent clearly god is
still using him
so he feels god is using me god has
forgiven me
i don't need to repent anymore and
you've you've started the cycle and
he'll keep on doing it
at the good that's happening you know
what's what's this little thing over
here
in the wake of what is transpiring over
yeah obviously god doesn't require
confession in his mind
god has swept it all under the carpet
because the good he's doing outweighs
the bad
yeah you're talking about the the
psychological and even
spiritual manipulation going on have you
guys heard like the testimonies of that
so yeah we have a thing on the screen
here it says this witness told us that
their relationship began as a normal
massage therapist client relationship
and she came to think of him as a father
figure the
illicit information about her faith and
her financial situation
she reported that after he arranged for
the ministry
to provide her with financial support
he required sex from her according to
this witness
mr zacharias used religious expressions
to gain compliance
as as she was raised to be a person of
faith she reported that
he made her pray with him to thank god
for the opportunity
they both received she said he called
her
his reward for living a life of service
to god
and he and he referenced the godly man
in the bible
with more than one wife she said he
warned her not to ever speak against him
or she would be responsible for the
millions of souls
whose salvation would be lost if his
reputation was damaged
yes okay the weight of that
just just that thought of not
not only like you know i think one of
the greatest things
that that you're going to experience
when you get to heaven is somebody
walking up to you and saying hey
i'm only here because you witnessed or
shared christ with me right that's one
of the greatest things on the flip side
of that one of the worst things you're
gonna
you hear is i'm not there or this person
didn't make it
this is something i did i mean that's a
heavy spiritual weight that you're just
placing on somebody right there
so can i i i want to respond please
respond with
breaking down the tools of abuse that
are behind
that chilling quote that you just read
yeah because this isn't just ravi
zacharias no that's not the part of the
course that's how spiritual abusers work
it's not just spiritual abusers that's
how sexual abusers emotional abusers
verbal abusers financial abusers work
it's just worse by an added layer
when someone with spiritual authority
puts god's name on top of the patterns
that they're using and then it becomes
spiritual abuse as well because you're
weaponizing that relationship that
desire for faith
to to in this sick and twisted way which
which causes
exponential damage to the victim's
picture of the character of god
absolutely
you're breaking the third commandment of
misrepresenting taking the name of the
lord in vain taking the name of christ
and then
misrepresenting the character of god in
the most egregious way like that but
what i want what i would love to do
right now is break down
four tools and four elements that are in
every abusive context
and these were developed by psalm 82
initiative
not not us so i like to give you which
is a fantastic ministry to follow if
anybody is wanting to understand more of
how abuse works follow psalm 82
initiative
on social media they're incredible so
we'll put that link in the description
below
psalm 82 yeah yeah their initiative
fantastic
and the resources that they put out are
amazing so i have permission
from their director to share these um so
in every
abusive situation there are four tools
and four relational elements and part of
why we don't see these
a lot of the time is because we are
focused on
the personality of the person so when we
look at the pedestal and the personality
we don't see the tools of abuse
until the scales have fallen off and
we're like wow
all of this evidence outweighs the
pedestal and the personality
but in the beginning there's there's
this
um weight of truth
and and we think well but the pedestal
and the personality i mean how could
they do that
we have them on a pedestal and they have
this incredible personality
and the charm so that's what we see and
there's this
burden of truth that has to rise higher
than the pedestal and the personality
in order for the average person who is
not trained
in seeing the tools and the elements of
abuse to be able to recognize that there
is something else going on here besides
just the pedestal and the personality so
that's
you you can't if you were someone
who is now saying how did i not see that
it's because you were normal human
because it's not necessarily your fault
you now have an
obligation to educate yourself so you
can do better
i mean you're not off the hook for
future doing better but if you are
someone who has been through a situation
like this and you're a leader or
whatever and you're like
i got it wrong i got it so wrong you
have to
be willing to say i didn't know the
tools
so those four tools are and this works
in every context well my phone just lost
it hold on a second let me pull it back
up
this works in every context not just
just domestic violence
not just spiritual abuse not just
workplace abuse whatever
the first tool of abuse is isolation
and you can see that like if you pull
that back up
um the the quote that you had
the first tool that he uses
is making her feel special
mm-hmm
every word is about making her feel
special that is
not about actually making her feel
special that is to isolate her from the
people around her
and he's already taken her out of her
cultural context and
family of origins so that she is already
she's physically absolutely
she's already isolated physically now he
has and that's why he would choose
somebody
from another environment like that often
and then
but we see this even in dating
relationships when we see someone who's
in a domestic violence relationship
maybe a clergy spouse or someone
10 years down into the marriage you can
look back into the dating relationship
and baby it's you and me against the
world maybe your parents really don't
understand you
you know your friends just don't get you
like i do you are the only one who
understands me
you're the only one i can rely on all of
those are isolating techniques
not healthy community right techniques
right so
it fosters allegiance to themselves the
abuser's self
while excluding and diminishing other
important relationships and the ultimate
end is that the the victim feels alone
and rejected and helpless
the second one is deflection so if you
imagine
deflection as so this is this is where
the abuser seeks to shift blame or
negative attention away from themselves
so imagine deflection if you're in like
sci-fi this is your force field shield
my kid would like this idea yeah so your
force field shield is
all the bad stuff slides off of me and
on to anyone else
so in an egregious child abuse situation
i would never have thrown the
two-year-old into the wall if they
hadn't been screaming for two hours
like i am not responsible to control
myself because the child was crying too
long
so i mean that's an extreme example but
we see small examples
just like what he said you are my reward
i'm not doing sin you are my reward
because i am a man of god so there's
that deflection of responsibility
the bad stuff slides off of me and on to
anything
else and it creates not just guilty and
indignant
for the the victim but it also creates a
sense of sympathy
you were pushed beyond your your your
threshold trying to understand why this
sin
your wife doesn't give you enough
attention oh now
i can't say no to you because i feel
sorry for you i feel sympathetic for you
you're a man in need yes yes i start
fighting
for you as your victim third is
manipulation so this is the opposite of
that force field shield
this is a magnetic shield all the good
stuff comes to me
so if there's credit if there's
limelight if there's a project done
doesn't matter who the team is
it's all mine you ever know anybody like
that
well i'm in his ministry i'm sure yeah
ravi is the one yeah
he's obviously a guy but i mean just
even in
everyday life there are people who
everything if there's something good
going on it all is about them and so it
bolsters their public image
and it gets you to do what they want
for reason of making things look good
that can even be like
at church we look perfect i don't care
if we were screaming at each other in
the car on the way
yeah right but you will not make me look
bad at church
yeah that's an interesting um you know
polarization on the one hand if it's bad
you know i had nothing to do with it
anything good though that was all me
exactly and you call evil good
and good evil which is the ultimate
technique i mean this is
this is what satan did in the garden
yeah he isolates them from
god has god said you can't have good
stuff he's keeping the best stuff for
himself
deflecting i'm the one who's trying to
exalt myself but now i'm going to
accuse god of being the one who's trying
to exalt himself and keep the highest
place but if you eat this fruit you get
it too
and then manipulation it all goes
together so i know you haven't finished
all this
stuff come on let me ask you this one
question then um
does he himself believe like really
believe
that god is rewarding him i mean is that
a realistic
view because then that's going to make
me say
i i question whether he believes what
he's actually saying then
i think i think that abusers like ravi
zacharias have moments of
flashes of insight but generally they
pick the reality they want to live in
and that's the one that they live in
because can you imagine
how you would feel as a godly man if you
accidentally slipped up and had a woman
in your hotel room and had sex with her
and that's just what would you do
to so many people with no choice
involved yeah at all
all of this doesn't even you know it's
hard for the normal
human christian to even comprehend like
i could never do that but if
if you did you would immediately see
that you'd
call your wife you would be living if
you couldn't somehow reach your wife
you would be in crushing crushing guilt
because someone
that god is gonna give you something
that is so sinful you know what i mean
but you have to choose the world that
you're gonna live in
if you don't wanna live in that constant
sense of crushing conviction of sin
you have to rationalize it and you never
would have gotten to the point where you
would do that
without a thousand rationalizations of
looking at low necklines and high
hemlines and fantasizing and watching
porn you do the low risk stuff first
yeah there's a there's a
world that's built up to that point
right so by the time you meet that
pornographic style of relating
yeah by the time you get to the point
where you can objectify a woman like
this
and dehumanize her knowing i am
you're gonna ruin your life so much more
difficult for her to have any connection
with god which is the real damage of
abuse it makes it harder for victims to
connect with god in meaningful ways so
here's a woman who you know i am making
it so much harder for her to love and
trust
god but that doesn't matter to me by the
time you get to that point
you have created your fantasy world and
you live in that so he
he i'm sure he was under conviction you
know if he was in an earthquake and he's
pinned in the basement of
a building and he's got three days to
sit there and think about if he needs to
repent for anything before he dies of
thirst
he knows exactly what to repent for so
on that level he's aware
but on another level absolutely not
you know the doctrine about one's safe
always safe
and talking to another christians that
they believe that
um they answered me
jesus forgive my sense of my past
present and future sins so i don't have
to not sin
yeah i don't have to confess i don't
have to read so i don't know i don't
know
too much about this ministry about uh
zechariah's ministry
or in details or what he believed in
that or not
but to me it's like we were talking
about like you know he thought about
this you are rewarded i can do this i
mean i don't know is the right thing
that he's
supposed to be doing yeah i don't know i
mean if you distill it down to a simple
belief i believe so therefore i'm going
to go to heaven
i mean i don't know i mean just to hear
that it's like wow
yeah this is where people say theology
doesn't matter only love matters no
theology matters
because theology of love is your
theology decides what your picture of
god is
how god handles sin how god handles
righteousness
i'm sorry it's heavy everything is about
good theology
not that a person can't be saved with
bad theology
but what we believe about god if we have
bad beliefs about god it makes us harder
for
it harder for us to love and trust him
and if we have good beliefs about god
that show him to be an
actual god of justice and mercy that
makes it easier to love him and to trust
him and to act in loving and trustworthy
ways
right to others because if we see god as
loving
and worthy of trust and as requiring
love and trustworthiness then we are
more likely to emulate that
so the last thing that in in your quote
that you posted um was that he warned
her
to not tell anyone because then the
ruining of
millions of souls would be on her not
him
not his exploitation of her but on her
telling
the truth the fourth tool
of abuse is intimidation and this is
where someone employs threats or actions
to promote sufficient fear
to get compliance and at that point the
victim feels hopeless paralyzed and
anxious
now that does not mean that it has to be
like a physical like domestic violence
kind of threat right right no you don't
have to do it at all to you and they
probably won't tell you at all
you know he was threatening suicide so
yeah but
being suicidal intimidation that she's
going to cause people to be lost
it's a mind game anything any mind game
that gets you to do what i want that's
best for me
and bad for you now i'm not talking
about when we tell our kids
to eat your vegetables okay you know you
have to do this and then we like help
our kids actually you know whatever you
need to do to get them either but it's
good for them
but when you're using mind games or
reverse psychology
or shifting blame to get someone to do
something that is ultimately endorsing
sin
and is bad for them in order to get you
off the hook
that's intimidation it's a tool of abuse
so if we are able to step back
when we see stuff like this come out
whether it's in your local church
or it's a news scandal or whatever and
we say
okay i'm going to ignore the name the
pedestal the personality
the charm do i see
isolation happening here do i see
deflection
happening here do i see any manipulation
happening here
do i see any tactics of intimidation
oh there is abuse going on
so what would you suggest in that
scenario if
you did notice something and all of a
sudden you're now presented with this
i need to say something or how would you
even begin to
well that's where you get that's where
it gets tricky and it depends i mean it
depends
is this is this your workplace is this
your boss is this a co-worker
is this your pastor the leader of an
international is it the leader of the
international administration
you know i want to throw something out
although ravi zacharias ministries
ignored this and silenced
those who had come forward and forced a
non-disclosure agreement on one of the
most vocal victims
and covered and covered and covered in
the
end they have been willing to pull all
of his books from circulation
and to shutter the ministry close it
down
now i don't know what they're going to
do next but in the end they have done
some of the right things now should
those things have been done years ago
yes
and it was obvious if you open your eyes
and with clear eyes look at the
situation the man was lying
he was hiding he was manipulating one
the one message that made it public was
very clear he was trying to manipulate
through suicide threats
so in my mind from day one once it came
out and i spent an hour looking at the
evidence
i was like nope it's clear but
but for people who were immersed in it i
realized it's very difficult for those
who are immersed
in a personality cult oh yeah to to go
what this ruins my whole life it's
taking a wrecking ball to their lives
right
and it's just like if you have a palace
and then here comes a wrecking ball
you're like whoa
wait so there are a few cracks we'll fix
it
we can renovate or this surely isn't
happening you know you don't want to
shatter your whole life so i understand
the motivation
that people have when their ministry is
threatened when their livelihood is
threatened when their family and
reputation and everything else is
threatened
but we have to choose is it the glory of
god
or my comfort and glory that matters
because i think there's also
you you you want to be wrong you know
what i mean like
your mind is playing these games where
you're just like no no i didn't see what
i saw
exactly and like i'm not hearing what
i'm hearing and like if i say
something and i'm wrong what would it do
to this person's
reputation and their ministry and i
could be ruining it so the abuse
that's happening directly from ravi to
this girl is also happening
to everyone else that he works with in
an indirect way yes
and and we what you just said is crucial
because we have to also say the flip
side of it
if i saw what i saw and i'm right
and i say nothing what continues to
happen to the person
or the child or the immigrant that that
is still
happening to because we think oh if i if
i saw what i saw and i'm wrong
i i will be responsible for ruining
millions of people's lives if i say
something about robbie
if i saw what i saw and i'm right
my silence allows that person to
continue suffering
instead of possibly right as we know
like child molesters according to
the book predators by anna salter child
molesters have an average of 50 to 150
victims before first
arrest just after that that's just more
after
yeah you know why my children are not
going outside
[Laughter]
yes but but the reason that there's so
many more before after first arrest
is because the as it should be the level
of
criminal evidentiary standard for
proving is very high
and that is that you've got to have
videotape and well
we should be able to understand patterns
of things but but it is important
in the justice system to have a very
high standard of criminal evidentiary
requirement in order to not be putting
people away
for false accusations so that's
important yeah we don't want some guy to
you know somebody to be upset they want
your studio
they make a false accusation you're
slammed in prison with no evidence and
that's it
so it has to be high but the reason that
they are
that predators are free to keep
molesting to keep abusing with impunity
after first arrest
is because that first arrest almost
never
nets enough criminal evidence to meet
that
evidentiary standard we deal with
situations
with multiple victims we've got five 10
20 victims coming ignored
and known but we don't have
any physical proof there's not a video
there's not an email saying you can't
tell what i did it's not and therefore
they're free and they continue abusing
in churches and that's hard
it is but see also this is really
important
the criminal evidentiary standard is not
our moral evidentiary standard for
church
see as church organizations in the faith
community
are not held to a criminal evidentiary
standard of proof in order
to take actions within we're not talking
about sending someone to prison
we're talking about taking actions for
safety of the vulnerable right
people need to know be aware
so in the church in the faith community
we are
simply help we are held to two standards
socially
we are held to the civil standard of
evidence and that is simply more likely
than not
our one of our lawyers says 50 plus a
feather if it's more likely than not
based on these tools of abuse based on
understanding the patterns of action
that this person is doing something you
have the obligation
civilly to take action to protect the
vulnerable
in your church not to protect the
alleged abuser
but in the faith community we have an
even higher standard than that
we have a moral standard set by god now
that doesn't mean we go vigilante
but it means that we have an obligation
to set a higher standard than
merely the civil evidentiary standard of
the world
and so it's okay to say
our church has a ton of families and
children
known sex offenders are not welcome
to fellowship freely here we will
minister to you
at home there are people who are
shut-ins there are people with physical
health problems there are people who
during covet never
were able to leave and they had to
worship with
online groups sex offenders can do the
same
you do not have to let the wolf into the
hen house or the sheepfold
in order to be loving to them
in fact it's not very loving to the wolf
to let them
in with the lambs and then say don't
touch anything
yeah so a couple of things i was
thinking about when you guys were
going through these these four different
identifying marks is
on on a bigger scale i can see that this
is exactly what satan does to every one
of us
you know he applies those same tactics
in our christian walk and then the other
thing i was thinking about is you know
to the to the victims
the the person who's abusing them
they're they're demanding
a certain identity if you will
and then they're swallowing up or or
managing to
erase the other person's identity
like completely because you you look at
these people that have gone through this
like
the the david crash incidences and the
jim jones incidences and the people that
walk away they're just like
they have no idea what to do with
themselves anymore it's like their whole
life was
wrapped up into this person and and
the whole facade that they created
you know this this alternate reality and
then after that
they they have no idea what to do
they're just like completely lost
it's like their whole their whole life
was wrapped up into that and it's like
they have no life anymore
i think that's why our identity has to
be found in christ
the cause and this is a note i wrote
down earlier there goes my lid
is the note i wrote down while you were
talking because if
what is okay you guys can probably help
me think of the term
but there's there's this term i was just
reading an article about it the other
day
about like when we don't want to quit
something because all of our level of
investment
what what is that keith help me yeah um
so um i was watching somebody on
i don't know i think it was instagram or
tic tac or something in like one of
those one minute videos and they were
talking about how
we tend to i know it was abraham piper
um
we tend to be hesitant to quit something
if we've put a lot of blood sweat and
tears into it
and so we'll keep going even if it's bad
because of our investment already
put in so when we are looking at someone
like ravi
or like any of these others i mean he's
a convenient
topic for this but but any of these
types of situations
very often what prevents people from
being able to say i was wrong about this
is because if they're wrong then i'm
wrong and my pride is so bound up in
how much i believe they're good my
investment is in
them being who they said they were that
if
i accept that they are not who they said
they were
then it it does this domino effect
because my identity is bound up in
worshiping their celebrity culture
because my identity is not plugged in
directly to god where i mean hey
if other people on pedestals fall it
doesn't matter to me because i know who
i am in god that vertical identity
so if we have those horizontal spokes
and identity where
they are feeding our sense of who we are
then if they're wrong i don't know who i
am anymore which is
a way of an aspect of that insane thing
and many people might not think that
they are in that situation because they
you know they didn't love ravi zacharias
he was one of a hundred preachers that
they really
stands for is this system right and if
he's wrong in that system then maybe the
system is flawed
and my identity is bound up in that
structure and not only identity but even
my safety
you know we all want to live in a world
where
if somebody gets hauled away in
handcuffs we go
i knew i always knew there was something
about him
and yeah so we don't want to live in a
world
we don't want to live in a world where
that guy is hauled away and we're like i
had no idea i never saw him coming
he's my next door neighbor yeah i
trusted him
yeah yeah yeah oh my goodness my kids
have been home without exactly you know
me there
you know or whatever we don't want to
live in a world like that we want to
live in a world where we could just tell
like we live in a movie and you can tell
from early on oh that guy has a look on
his face okay he's the bad guy you know
we want to think that that's that's what
we can do but the reality is we can't
and when somebody close to us is
guilty and we had no idea it wrecks our
whole world it's like now who's safe
i don't know who's safe anymore i didn't
see this coming at all
so it's one more reason there are many
reasons for what we call perpetrator
bias
where the moment that somebody makes an
allegation everybody clusters to
the side of the alleged perpetrator and
they're like no no we're not going to
believe that until you know
i'm not going to ruin the life of an
innocent man he's innocent until proven
guilty as far as i'm concerned
that kid you know we find some way to
put this person down
so that we can side this person it's
partly just human nature it's carnal
nature to want to be able to trust our
gut
to want to be able to say no this guy is
good i i was
so inspired by his sermons or whatever
it is
we don't want to live in that world and
and perpetrators
maximize the benefits of that that's why
they claw their way to positions of
power that's why they go out of the way
as
yeah and that but like um in in um
predators by anna salter she told she
interviewed
predators in prison and they told the
stories
of what they would do when guy was like
yeah i have mowed lawns for old ladies
i bought food for the poor years yeah
because i wanted to be sure that if
anybody ever caught me that
the whole church would stand up behind
me which is exactly what they did
yeah so so i think if anybody spends
time
in ministry and you could see behind the
doors
you will actually see that really it's
not cracked up to be
exactly what you think it is a church
board meeting yeah
yeah yeah you know what i mean like i
i've worked with the church and
alongside the church
long enough to know wow it's really like
this behind here but
but i don't want to scare people out of
that but i think we need a really help
why not
well i think we need a real healthy
realistic view of we're all human
all in the same level we cannot be
putting these things up here
just because we appreciate or admire
their message over here or even because
this person preaches
powerful truths right what is it says
that great oration and powerful
theological words sometimes flow out of
a heart of corruption
and they are not one does not equal the
other now with that
this is kind of like devil's advocate
you guys were saying that some of his
books were not
being sold anymore what do you think
about that he spoke
truth and yeah he did shameful terrible
things
but should we remove books of truth off
the shelf
books that created atheists into
believers
yes that's a very good question because
it does harm to have those books out for
several reasons for one thing imagine
that you're one of his victims
and you see his books being sold or
being quoted on social media
or him being praised in some way number
two imagine you're not his victim but
you're a victim of someone else like him
and that's about 38 percent of women who
are are victims by the age of 18
statistically
we're seeing in research now have been
sexually assaulted or abused by the age
of 18 38
so imagine you're a victim of someone
like him and you see that
or imagine that you're a perpetrator and
you are like him and now you're like
see my books will go on my sermons will
go on
if i can just keep my victims quiet
at least until i die ravi's story
is a warning to predators
to men who are addicted to porn to
people who are hiding things
and saying i'll never get caught i can
keep it quiet
i'm going to beat my kids but then i'll
give them ice cream and that'll make up
for it and they'll never tell
you know to those people this is a
wake-up call and
to robbie's enablers if they had stood
up and said we're going to do an
investigation
now when the first victim came forward
he might have been saved
he might have been brought to repentance
and he never will be now
because they neglected their duty okay
now let me throw one more little monkey
wrench into here
what if ravi were to have come to
terms with what he had done it came out
in the open
he was still alive and he said he was
sorry would that
change his books being out okay so if he
had repented
if he had
so here's the thing you game this out
with me
how did he repent and why is it because
he got caught
and exposed and then he's like oh man
crocodile tears i am
so sorry i am so wrong
please keep buying my books yes this is
true
this is true because if he did get
caught you would think that you know
your true repentance would be
for you to remove if he got caught
then to show repentance the appropriate
course of action would have been for him
to step down
go live in isolation not isolation like
as in no community but go live in
invisibility somewhere
go be somewhere that you have a lot of
power
over others and voluntarily
remove your materials from the shelves
because you know
those being there causes harm to those
you have hurt
and sets a poor example for anyone else
who's like you
do the right thing by your materials by
the people you've harmed
and go live a quiet
no limelight kind of life if he had done
that
better yet if he had come public with no
one finding out and said i
am not worthy of the accolades
and the public attention because this is
what i've been doing
in my private life i'm voluntarily
confessing i am removing myself
from the position of power that is like
crack cocaine to someone
who decides that they're going to get
away with stuff like this
i will not tempt myself with having any
influence
or or power over anyone else
now what would you well when would be a
publicly
of somebody like that if you know if he
would he'd be getting movie deals
i'm telling you it would people would be
like i can respect that
i can respect you coming to the table
without somebody catching this is the
problem
because then he'd be getting he'd be
getting script offers from hollywood
yeah over and over i've seen this i see
a perpetrator start the process of
repentance genuinely
they start confessing they tell me what
they did they tell me their names the
names of their victims
and then the whole thing gets
short-circuited by their enablers who go
oh we're so glad you did this and the
next thing you know
the guy backs off from his confession
and
continues in his course of promoting
himself in ministry and says well i did
have a little slip
up minimizes what he did and blames
others i should have been more connected
with god things were not so good with my
wife but
whatever it is so we short circuit the
process
ravi to get to the point where he could
behave the way that he was behaving
was not a momentary thing it was years
of searing his conscience and sinning
against the holy spirit
and to give him any more power would
have been to put him right back in the
place of temptation if he were really
sorry
he would withdraw his books from the
market and he would take all of his
money and fund
funnel it into helping his victims which
is
a zacchaeus moment and that would be i'm
going to give him that would be true
as much and then that's true never seek
the limelight again that's true
see you have um julian chavigian
is another name of someone who did
similar types of things
uh one of billy graham's grandsons um
well-known
one of many who's done this kind of
thing got caught
did exactly follow that exact formula
you know things weren't so great with my
wife i'm so sorry i did this i'm going
to take some time off
justified at least in some ways just
take creativity they all do the same
thing
it's like there's this playbook but it's
just the textbook
and then within 16 18 months
back oh he's starting a new church no
oversight
no board he's just doing his own thing
he's popped back up
same thing with john crist the comedian
who it came out that he was having
inappropriate relationships and
pressuring women and that kind of thing
so he drops off the scene for about six
months gives a really big crocodile to
his apology
and guess what i see he's making new
videos on youtube he's got people
flocking back to him
more famous because more people have
heard about that exactly here's the
thing
genuine repentance confesses everything
and it takes full responsibility doesn't
blame anybody else
and it accepts consequences you contrast
that with adam and eve and kane
they go oh what are what what is it that
i did no i didn't they hide
they minimize they lie right then once
they're caught and they can't hide
minimize and lie anymore they blame
and then finally with kane we see the
next
characteristic my punishment is too
great for me to bear
and that is your recipe and when you see
any of those three characteristics
you know true repentance hasn't happened
it is not bearing fruits yet because
they hide minimize and lie they blame
and then they
complain that the consequences are too
great for them to bear my one complaint
with kanye west i know totally sad topic
but
if you if you truly have a repentant
heart
you would take away things that you have
slammed god
and that you've put your name on there
you are jesus making money off of it you
would literally be like please
burn that album and take it out of your
life i want it removed from everybody's
site because i
defied my god in that thing the fact
that it's still out there in the world
yeah so in we see this same thing in the
domestic violence community
same pattern it's the same see none of
it is about sex
none of it is about anger it's all about
power and control
really at the root of it it's about not
having a healthy relationship
with the truth because i lie to myself
about god and i lie to myself about
myself which means i am free to lie to
everyone else about god
and myself and themselves because i
don't have
a transparent radical relationship with
the truth
so in it's just it's a power and control
thing
sexual abuse is a power this is where
it's not a sex thing this is where you
have to realize that
everything is about the character of god
satan's first lie was that god
was exalting himself ye shall be his
gods if you just eat this fruit you're
going to get to that position that he's
trying to reserve for himself he's like
a mom
keeping the best chocolates for herself
and eating them in the closet
but if you eat this fruit you get what
god tried to hold back from you god is
withholding good gifts
so satan said god wants to keep power
and control
out of selfish reasons abuse is about
keeping power and control for selfish
reasons
and that's why it's diametrically
opposed to the character of god
[Laughter]
is a lot of self-promotion and
exaggeration and all those things okay
so let's deal with a little bit of that
even if his stuff was good
but i don't wanna i don't wanna leave it
there i wanna i wanna
finally come around is there hope for
someone like
are we just doing one segment because i
mean this might be five hours long
block out your whole afternoon because
we're going for this you know what i
wasn't even gonna go here
but let me just um tell you see i see
this band i wear on my arm
this is a reminder to pray for one of my
best friends
my friend is in prison for child
molestation
he was one of my best friends in high
school he was the first guy
i ever admitted to that i had been
sexually abused
and i did it because he he tuned in so
well
he heard that i've been crying in class
when sexual abuse came up and he came to
me alone he said are you okay nicole
did something happen to you this was in
high school i was 18.
he said if something ever happened to
you and you got abused i want you to
know it's okay it doesn't make you bad
and i was abused when i was a kid too
and my mom will help you he talked to
his mom his mom gave me a book
he cared he cared deeply and
i trusted him so much when i found out
that he was arrested a few years ago
i was absolutely shattered and
mine was the first letter he got in
prison i wrote to him and i said
the grace of god goes as low as where
you are what you have done is horrific
i did not see this coming i could not
have imagined that you would do this
but if you will confess if you will
repent if you will
do what you know you need to do now
there is still hope for you
and he did he confessed everything he
told me later that
when they came to his door he was
terrified but he was also relieved
because he said i didn't have to live
the lie anymore he hadn't been living as
a christian he hadn't been pretending to
be a christian
but he told them everything he had done
he pleaded guilty
he'll be in prison for decades but he's
free
and and he told me when i said what
message would you want me to give
to others like you he said he that
covers his sins shall not prosper but
whoever confesses and
forsakes them shall have mercy this is a
man who is in prison for child
molestation but he has apologized to the
best of his ability to his victims
he has taken full responsibility he does
not blame anyone else for what happened
and i believe he is on his way to the
kingdom i can't wait to see him in
heaven
this is the process of healing a
predator
very very rarely will you find someone
who will be willing to do that
because they have seared their
conscience this is a
persistent sin against the holy spirit
kind of issue
but those who will turn around and say
lord i give you everything and i'm
willing to face
any consequences can have mercy
i mean that's that's um an example as
well as the
thief that was sitting there next to
christ i mean isn't it isn't it he was
basically mocking him at one point
doesn't the bible kind of
say that they were both jarring at jesus
like you know come on can't you come
down and save us
only to later then say okay
i we are here because of what we did
this man didn't do anything like this
and jesus
saves him from that point i mean he had
minutes probably to
live at that point but i think that true
confession
from his heart was literally like if
time would have progressed on
he truly would have been sorry for what
he would have done he realized at that
point
i need to have a change now your friend
um would you say that he was abused as a
child as well
he did not um properly deal with it or
it was not something that he was able to
handle therefore
down the road he perpetuated that he
hadn't processed his abuse
and that is that is a factor that we've
talked about
um because he wasn't given
the resources the gospel initiative
didn't happen
for him people did not help him and
things could have been very different
only a fraction of those who are abused
become abusers but i will say this the
best and the worst people in the world
come from the same category of people
those who have been hurt deeply those
who have suffered deep injustice
we become either those who hate those
things
and decide i will have nothing to do
that or we are crippled
and we re return to the cycles maybe not
sexually abusing because we were
sexually abused
but maybe retaining power and control
issues
in other areas of life if we do not take
refuge in the justice of god
knowing god will make every wrong right
my job is to be on his
side if we don't take refuge in that we
always duplicate the patterns of evil in
some way
that's why it's so important for an
abuse victim to get refuge in the
character of god to understand
god is gonna fight for you he may not be
able to give justice in this world
because if he made every wrong right
why would we look forward to heaven how
would we see
revealed the character of satan so god
says i can't fix it all now
i have to let evil bear its logical
fruit so that the whole world will see
and go we do not want this to ever exist
in the universe again
then i can take care of it but at some
point god will make all the wrongs right
yeah that's why the ultimate abuser has
not been dealt with at this moment
yes yes and and i want to throw some
data
in um just to support the gospel
side of things that you just shared
because that is a really common question
and it is exactly one of the deflection
tactics
oh but i was abused as a child oh i'm so
sorry
now i understand why you're raping
little kids
so no full stop screech halt
do not pass go do not collect 100
dollars lots of people
far more than are reported have
experienced abuse and trauma as children
if anything our rates of child abuse are
under
reported not over reported and
under-dealt with not over-dealt with
only six out of every 1 000 rapists not
just rapes
rapists will spend even one day in jail
6 out of 1
000 wow it's not even like a percent
it's like a
so and and that isn't going to prison
for a proper term for what they've done
that's one
night in jail like overnight
so
not all the time not every time but
there's there's
there's usually a missing quality right
so there's something to follow or a
woman who says you groped me
and it's her word against his unless
there's a video camera trained on them
nothing's going to happen if it didn't
happen in the elevator and even then if
you're a football player it doesn't
count
right right where there was cameras yeah
exactly
so but but just some data on that so
more than 60
according to anna salter's research in
the book predators which
is on my recommended reading list on my
website i give you that
um that's a free giveaway i'm happy to
throw out there nice uh it's like
best books of everything on all these
topics
um but in that book more than 60 percent
of child abusers sexual abusers
say and they claim to manipulate their
audience
that they were abused as children and
that is why they act out when given
the opportunity to make that statement
on a polygraph
the number of those who still say they
were abused as children drops below 20
really so and in londy bancroft's book
which is another great one it's also on
my list of recommended reading called
why does he do that inside the minds of
angry and controlling men
so when men would come to him in his
domestic violence intervention
programs and processes when men would
come to him and be like you don't
understand how my mother was
you don't understand what i went through
as a kid this is how i was treated
and he would just answer then you know
what it's like to be on the other end of
it
why are you doing it to anyone if you
know what it's like to receive that
and then they're like you don't
understand what
because that's only a convenient
deflection
that's right it's a manipulative
justification it's a justification
so the majority of people who
are abused in childhood do like you said
they may grow up to
continue generational patterns of power
and control or
emotional wounding that kind of thing
but they do not grow up
to overtly exploit children and commit
sexual abuse of others
because they would rather give an arm
and a leg than have anything happen to
another child like what happens to them
yeah so it is a choice to
exploit others and it is a deflection
to say it's because somebody did
something bad to me when i was a kid
you know one of the things i appreciate
about god is that even though
there's a lot of these cases and from
what you say statistically the majority
of them
that they go free there's no there's no
punishment or there's not enough
evidence to convict
god i'm glad that god is a god who he is
recording everything
and one day he's going to lay out all
the evidence on the table
all the proof there is no hiding it says
in ecclesiastes 12 14
for god will bring every work into
judgment including
every secret thing whether good or evil
and so we serve a god of justice and
even if
somebody in this world hasn't
experienced justice like they should
that day is coming and god will make
everything right and this is where i
think it's important to mention how
forgiveness works
as a victim of childhood sexual abuse
myself i had a terrible time forgiving
i felt like my abuser's hand was
gripping my ankle
everywhere i went from his grave he
couldn't
he would never let me go and i could
never get married and i could never have
children and i could never have a normal
family
and that haunted me for years until i
realized
and god just spoke to me he said nicole
i will take care of it
and i will do a better job of giving
justice than you ever possibly could
and i realized at that point because my
unbelief and the character of god
was leading me to think he's not ever
going to make this right i was trying to
make it right by resenting
by holding on to that anger so at least
somebody
would remember what happened to me but
once i realized
no god is going to take care of it he's
going to do a better job than
i ever possibly could i was released
to say i don't have to hold on to it
he's got it all written down
and he's going to make it right maybe my
abuser repented on his deathbed and
never had a chance to say sorry in that
case
we'll get to heaven and he will give me
a heartbroken apology
and because he's there i will have
confidence somehow god will give me the
confidence to know this guy is safe now
for all of eternity if not god will give
him what he deserves and in
any case it's all really about the
character of god
and i know this i'm free i identify with
god uh you know being a father of a
daughter i would tie a noose around
somebody's neck and throw it in the
depth of the sea
and make sure they drown just in that
stand until the bubbles are gone
i thought of somebody like hurting my
daughter i mean just boils my blood
yeah but you got to think like god god's
gotta he's got it's
revenge is his and god loves the abuser
this is the thing at the end god will
give justice
and he will be able to love the abuser
at the very
end if i were to try to get justice on
anyone who were to abuse one of my
children i would have to turn my mind
off
from empathy for them i would have to
dehumanize them wait
god will never do do you even get
justice or get vengeance vengeance
you're right
for the guys who for me to do what
really they deserve
and there's no way you can actually do
that in this world you can never make up
for all those years for all that torment
but you can do our your best to be on
the side of god who is just
when jesus rises up against abusers when
he rebukes
when he stands up for the vulnerable
throughout the new testament
he is giving us an example of what we
are called to do in abuse situations
i think that's a really important
distinction to me yes it is because
as a survivor of abuse as an onlooker
who loves someone who is
a survivor or victim of abuse we have
a i believe a gospel mandate to seek
justice
to pursue justice i mean micah 6 8
he has shown you a man what is good
counts for women too but to what
do justly to love mercy
and to walk humbly these two make up the
third
but it's not love justice and do mercy
which we often get backwards it's do
justice
with a heart of mercy what is most
merciful to someone who is perpetrating
abuse and harming
it's to be stopped from perpetrating
so the most loving merciful thing you
can do
for someone who is exploiting another
person
is to prevent them from continuing to
exploit the other person
take the wolf out of the the out of the
sheepfold out of the hen house
that you you have to do justice
in order to love mercy otherwise
we apply the law to the victim and the
mercy to the perpetrator
the victim is left in prison and the
perpetrator is set free to keep harming
but so seeking justice a lot of people
get this really confused with
forgiveness they're like
but if you forgive why do you still want
consequences for them i don't know maybe
because i want them to stop
maybe because i don't want anyone else
to keep harming maybe because that's the
only way
to bring them to the point of salvation
and recognizing that their sin
hurts people so justice
is needed and fighting for justice
when someone is acting in a pattern of
abusive
tools and behaviors is a requirement
unless you want to take scissors and cut
the books of isaiah and ezekiel and
psalms and everything right out of the
bible
they're all about god's heart for
justice
for the vulnerable but
vengeance is withheld from us vengeance
is the one thing god says is mine we
you cannot as humans you cannot have
vengeance
why because we
will do it wrong and we'll do it for the
wrong motives because only god can see
beginning from the end
and only god can recognize which course
of action
has the greatest potential of bringing
repentance
for the perpetrator we cannot see
beginning from the end
we might want to go and just eliminate
this
perpetrator from the earth but we don't
know what
other consequences would come from that
rash action
and also we as humans cannot
humanly it is impossible to divest
our emotions and our our
desire for them to suffer
from what is best for their
good god is the only one who can act
with that dispassionate i know what is
best for their good
so vengeance is off the table for us but
justice is not
and one can fully and completely forgive
and still
battle tirelessly for justice and
consequences
those two do not mutually exclude each
other well they actually
have to go together if i love this
person i must seek to give them painful
consequences because painful
consequences are the only thing they're
going to pave the way for them to repent
you know otherwise it's going to be a
quick shallow repentance this is why
david gets painful consequences even
after he has confessed
because he isn't really there yet he's
not really repeating he has to see the
cause you're not exciting the
consequence because then what that's
going to do is train the person oh if i
just ask for forgiveness then i'm
getting out of the consequences
sorry motive of your repentance becomes
wrong
it's cheap grace and it leads to
glossing over
sin and sin kills i think the
consequence also gives this
space in time for fruit to be born
yes you know because you can say well
you should forgive them and just you
know
unless we hit the reset button now
everything's back to normal well no it's
not back to normal
you know there's there's been damage
done so you need that space and time for
fruit to be
born to prove that there has been change
that there's been repentance since
there's been reconciliation
and that goes back to that first law in
the garden because
i know you've you've talked about this
too but there's but there's another
element
that i want to bring up the first lie in
the garden is you shall not surely die
you can do what you want and their sin
won't kill things there will be no
consequence
so when we allow painful consequences
for
exploitation for egregiously
misrepresenting the character of god for
harming other people when we allow those
painful consequences
it it gives that time for that extended
reset
but it also reminds
everyone involved that sin kills things
you can't just keep expecting
all your relationships and all your
career and all of your stuff to flourish
with just a quick oopsies so
it has to have time for death
the death of trust the death of
relationship and it takes
years for that to be reborn and it may
never look the same again
after certain types of betrayal that's
an interesting concept that there there
was actually a consequence in the garden
of eden before there was actually the
sin
you eat this you will die that's the
consequence of your action
because god is a goddess before this
happens you get to know yes
yeah it wasn't an after the fact that it
was this is going to be the consequence
and the snake came in the serpent's
message is
no you won't nothing's going to die you
can still have everything you want you
can do what you want
and have everything you want and you're
still going to keep everything you like
and so you're going to be like in fact
you're going to be
better than you are do what you want
defy god and you're going to be
better off than you were and so when
pastors counselors church leaders
say oh you need to go back and forgive
him
you need to go back and and submit
better re-engage clean relationships
re-engage in relationship
what they are doing is they're basically
stroking the head of the snake in the
tree and saying you shall not surely die
you shall not have any consequences
there doesn't have to be any death of
trust in your marriage even though you
have abused your wife and your children
there doesn't have to be any death of
your cons of your career in your
pastoral ministry even though you've
been caught doing
things that no pastor should do
and so they are when leaders
rush to reconciliation rapid restoration
um bringing people back together we want
to just
move forward everyone forgets put a
thick layer of frosting over it yep
what they're doing is perpetuating the
first lie
they're they're being the serpents
flying monkeys
yes in the tree and and you look at it
what
eve fell for was the idea that
god's not he's so loving he's not going
to do something bad to me
she fell for the lie that god's love was
more mercy than justice
interesting god's love is the perfect
combination of mercy and justice
but eve was like nah i can't imagine him
doing anything terrible like he wouldn't
kill us
and in doing so she mislabeled love
as soft fluffy stuff it's all mercy and
no justice and as a church
we've done the same thing we've said
well when a perpetrator does something
we've got to give him mercy we've got to
understand where he was coming from i
got to hear his side of the story well
they'll
always be his side of the story from an
abuser because of all those manipulation
tactics that they're going to use and
their life is on the line you think of
how
how tempted you are to lie when a
policeman pulls you over and says
how fast were you going and everything
in you is like
i don't i don't remember you know you
multiply that by 50
000 and you've got the temptation of an
abuser to lie
i have a funny story when i was a a
teenager
i used to drive really fast there was
like two speeds like full speed and not
right
and so i got pulled over in um loma
linda one time
and i know i was doing 95 miles an hour
and when he pulled me over
he said you know you know you i got
caught you do in 89 and i was like no
you didn't
and i knew he did not catch me at 89
because i knew i was doing
you technicality person you tell me
radar be at 89 and i was like
because i knew i was doing faster than
that but it's funny that we
when was the last time you calibrated
your radar machine officer
because you're
you know based on god's love this
happens all the time in christianity
but i always like that one thought that
you know eve
ate a piece of fruit like
we're justifying some evil sick stuff
okay yeah abuse is not i hit my thumb
and set aside
i did not eat a pear when i was told not
to you know what i mean like
like that that seems like such a
benign thing but it was it was the same
thing that we also totality
the same power and control behind it no
matter what it is and it's like
we're finding ways to try to justify
these terrible terrible things
but but a big part of that i mean we
have this whole justification culture
right oh well you know
it's the deflection of manipulation but
a big part of that also
ties into how we tend to define
any of the accumulation of these series
of choices like you've talked about is
this
thousand choices that somebody thought
didn't matter no one ends up in a hotel
room with someone with the opposite sex
that is that they aren't married to
without having made
a hundred or a thousand choices that got
you to that point unless you were
drugged
and dropped off there i mean i suppose
there could be you know exceptions to
that rule but you didn't knowingly get
there
accidentally but we we have this this
language
that is enabling
like i suffered a moral fall
no you didn't you felt where you were
standing you walked yourself right up
into the middle of the cesspool
like you know how you were talking just
before we got on the show keith about
the boys
getting out into the the pond and
they're covered in like algae and mud
nobody fell from 10 feet off the edge of
the pond into the center
you watch yourself they came up to them
yeah yes yes
so there is no such thing as a moral
fall it doesn't
exist there are a thousand tiny steps
that you ignored
until you got to the edge of the cliff
and the next logical step was
off the cliff and then when you're
picking yourself up from the bottom of
the cliff you're like
oh darn i had a moral fall no you didn't
you walked yourself there
right into the middle of the mud puddle
or the scum pond whatever it is
you took yourself step by step there
that's why joshua 24 15 says choose you
this day
whom you will serve not out of some
fear-mongering
abusive evangelistic tactic that's like
if you go home tonight and you die in a
car wreck
you don't know if you'll be saved or not
stop with that nonsense
you're more scared of the consequence
therefore you're gonna but
it it's not because of fear of
consequences and it's not because back
in the early israelite time that jesus
is going to come tomorrow
the second time he hadn't come the first
time yet so how is he going to come back
again
it's because the choice i make today
turns me into the person i am tomorrow
and then the choices i make that day
turn me into the person i am a year from
now
and in a year or five years i will
be of more tender conscience or i will
be of more hardened conscience
and i will either be able to see the
fruit of the spirit
developing in my life or i won't even
recognize a great moral leap because i
have walked myself
at every fork in the road so choose this
day because of
neuroscience because of brain patterns
because my choices today inform my
feelings which inform my habits which
actions which inform my habits which
create my character which defines my
destiny and it starts with how i think
the choice i make today this is where
often incidentally
when a church leader has been exposed as
potentially an abuser
we can evaluate the things that they say
in response
and see patterns that are going on they
don't realize that they're showing their
thoughts another um prominent abuser sam
pippim
and i i walked my students in counseling
class through
um what had happened and then i said but
here is his confession letter
the first time he was caught as a rapist
and and of course he didn't abuse he
didn't admit what he had done
but i said go ahead and read just the
first half of this
confession letter and they read it i
said give me some
ideas what do you see in there that
shows you whether he's telling the truth
or not
and they just rip the thing apart you
were like look at that sentence
because i had given them the simple
steps of hide minimize and lie
blame and um complain that your
punishment is too great for you to bear
and they're like look everywhere he's
saying those things and like see
it's right there almost every sentence
and they're like why did church leaders
let this guy go back because of pedestal
and personality
yes and he was because people don't want
to believe
what they see right in front of their
eyes if they've already chosen the
reality they would like to live in
and this brings us back to sobering
situations like ravi zacharias
with him he could have potentially
possibly
been able to repent and everything that
we're doing
in a ministry where we try to help
abusers is to bring
every person to the cross by whatever
method
is best and most helpful for them right
and that means we're
working for the salvation of abusers
we're working for the salvation of
victims
we're working for the salvation of those
who have not yet been enablers
by this person yes and we're working for
the salvation of the people who surround
the abuser
who need to have the scales off of their
eyes it's like we see what god is trying
to do
and from beginning to end that complete
restoration pattern and then
it's like we try to step in and say that
we have enough wisdom
to do as god would do and we short
circuit and we don't
you know right god has a process and and
and he he has he's the one that sees the
end from the beginning and so he is the
one
that only has the wisdom to work things
out according to the plan that's why
you don't you don't just restore people
back immediately to where they were
because it's not a wise thing to do it's
not good for them it's not good for them
it's not good for anybody right and so
you don't put the cocaine addict
in a room with little packets of cocaine
and say now don't touch anything
now we're gonna leave the room and just
leave you to do whatever you're gonna
do and you have to be so profoundly
addicted
to come to the point where someone like
him he's risking his family his
reputation
his very life and his
everything his money and his
relationship with god
how can you possibly come to the point
where you would be willing to risk
even your relationship with god never
mind everything else in your life
if you were not so profoundly addicted
that you have almost no control anymore
that's why a person like that is
does it even work here's here's
something i'm gonna throw out another
book
another research resource and that is
the sociopath next door by marsha stout
that one is so good one in 25
people that's four out of every hundred
are sociopaths
we define a sociopath a sociopath is a
person with no conscience
which we should we can do anything to
this at the end of time not as the level
of
growth so if one in 25 people
have no conscience now that does not
mean that four people out of every 100
are serial killers
or child predators because not
everyone's personality and temperament
and interesting
is to act on that kind of thing it
doesn't mean that
everyone who's a sociopath is going to
become a hardened criminal but it does
mean that
if you have 500 people in your church
you have yeah four no
no there's four in 100 you have 16
no no 20 we are not
[Laughter]
you have 20 people who are capable of
anything
within their sphere of parameters of
their interests and their personality
and not feeling the need to do anything
about it
not having that sense of conscience so
when you have someone like robbie
who fits all of these criteria i can't
diagnose him i'm not a psychiatrist
and he's dead but when you just look at
the pattern of evidence
and and you see someone who has these
characteristics
it's very likely you're asking don't do
they know
it's very likely that he chose like you
said the reality he wanted to believe
and that's what he ran with and he
actually didn't feel
bad because a person with no conscience
they're wired different a sociopath when
we see this in domestic violence
there are men who actually
if if you're a victim of something you
get a carjacking what happens to your
blood pressure
it's going up if somebody's accusing you
of something and you know you're
innocent
innocent what's happening to your blood
pressure it's going up
there are people sociopaths whose blood
pressure
drops and their brain waves turn back to
normal when they are acting out against
someone
because the way that they are
functioning
is that it makes them feel better
the thrill of acting out in power and
control
is actually soothing so that sense of
i might be doing something wrong i don't
want to get caught
they feel the opposite when they're
acting out
so we apply this whole sense of
they must just be carrying this weighty
guilt and burden
no they probably aren't so if they're
going through this
biological process where they're feeling
better more than likely they're probably
getting a hit of dopamine
serotonin all of this and so then it's
like a drug to them they get addicted to
it
and it reinforces the behavior like any
typical addiction you have to get higher
hits to get the same rush
so they have to start abusing kids in
public there's like you have to start
doing things that are worse
there's a television show that i just
saw a advertisement
for about a serial killer and he was
basically telling
the the um person that was interviewing
him just saying
i have to kill to feel normal and it's
like the more that they wanted
that's what i'm describing
so you see that with sexual predators
you see that with porn addicts
you see that with um people who act out
in domestic violence at home
you see that with any of these kinds of
things where there's this long
established pattern
that's their healthy baseline
not healthy but it's where they feel
safe and
broken their happy place it's their
happy place so
we talked about the four tools and
before we wrap up i would love to share
the four abusive relational elements
because this is crucial to bookend
if you are someone who wants to be able
to see past the power in the pedestal
and the personality
right the first one is entitlement
the idea that i have a right to power
so the benefit for the abuser is that
they maintain privilege
whatever that privilege is the privilege
of their position the privilege of
control the money the privilege of
control the privilege of
elevated status whatever it is and the
victim's painful experience is
unjustice or injustice and unfairness
the second relational element
entitlement and then
control and this is the security
for the privilege right it keeps
everything flowing
in in a comfortable
pattern for the abuser the victim
experiences insecurity and fear
the third relational element is when
entitlement and control intersect
and that becomes coercion so i have the
right
to take the control and power now i am
going to make you do it
and that is the acting out of power over
the victim experiences that is
oppression so we see this in
generational trauma we see this in
racism we see this
in sexism we see this in
any type of it's so this is not just
limited to
sexual abuse among clergy this is a
broad
scope that opens our eyes to what's
going on and we see it especially
in like epidemic proportions in
countries or cultures
where there's a sense of yes
has a right to be in power and everyone
else has a responsibility to submit it's
especially
accepted that you know uh it's just the
way that life is especially if you can
say
god put them this way that's the
ultimate weapon because if you stand up
against it you're standing up against
god yeah
yeah exactly and how can you ever combat
that especially when they start going
god told me this or
god put me here to do that whatever and
we all know that cult leaders do those
kinds of things
but on a low low-key level that is
cultural in their
entire cultures where that is
the expectation and the norm and
we see devastating results of that in
church culture
so we have those first three entitlement
control
which create together coercion and the
fourth one
is an action a relational bene a
relational element
on the part of the victim whoever the
victim is the fourth one
is compliance now the destructive
horrific unpleasant abusive system
will roll along smoothly just fine as
long as the victim is providing
compliance
yeah now it's not a healthy system it's
a toxic system
but it will operate and function
smoothly as long as the victim goes
along with it
this is why in domestic violence
situations we say and
data proves that the most dangerous time
for any woman is when she decides to
leave she is removing compliance
and it throws a monkey wrench in all of
the smooth well-oiled workings of the
abusive machine
so when someone a victim speaks up
and says ravi zacharias abused me she is
removing compliance from the system
and it is all hands on deck to silence
yeah the one who has removed compliance
we must keep the system
running smoothly so we silence the one
speaking out
and we'll see that from the outside and
the ravi zacharias ministries and go wow
that's terrible i can't believe they did
that
i wouldn't have but it'll be all
different when it happens in our church
to our buddy who we wouldn't have seen
coming and that doesn't seem like
him at all and we'll do the same thing
because that's human nature apart from
the spirit of god
anyway go ahead no no that i mean that's
the four things so you have entitlement
control mixed together create coercion
and it only
operates well if there is compliance
so if you have a situation where
someone has been i don't know trucking
along just fine in their church
but the clergy
have a choke hold a stranglehold on what
everyone gets to do and not do
it's fine until someone steps up and
says hey this isn't really like jesus
i actually want to think for myself over
here i actually have this thing i've
been studying and then it's just like
oh burn i'm at the stake whether it is
sexual abuse whether it is the
inquisition
whether it is um some sort of
some form of power and control in a
domestic violence situation
sister so and so in charge of potluck
who says it's always got to be my way
and we as a church we just comply
in charge of potlucks for 50 years
nobody wants to upset the fruit basket
and it'll stay that way and abusers
won't be confronted
and victims won't be freed and the
entire system will enable
sin to continue unconfronted in the
church for generations
and their schools too you know yeah
school schools too kind of
witness high schools you know because of
whatever title parents the kids that can
do whatever they want
yes and abusers abusers crave power
so they're going to put themselves into
positions of power
and and all the way around this causes
a need a desperate need for the church
to confront this because ultimately this
is all about a lot a lie about the
character of god
that we duplicate the character of god
when we set up
institutions and families in systems of
power and control where those in
authority
have the power over those under their
and instead of the person with authority
having the greatest
responsibility to serve to minister to
be the foot washer
to use their power to lift up those that
they're responsible for
we use the opposite and authority
becomes the reason why i have the right
to crush and control
and then we've paved the way for nobody
to repent and for everybody to have a
horrible picture of the character of god
then we're shocked when victims leave
the church and say i want nothing to do
with christianity of course not
because they want nothing to do with
this kind of christ being crushed the
devil's lie
is that god is controlling and he's the
one that's actually
placing all that control on god's
basically saying look i'm letting this
go you are free to eat from that tree or
not eat from that tree
i'm not forcing you you have the the
opportunity to choose that
it's the devil that's like no you know
i'm gonna force you now and
if you don't do what i say and we see
that now in our world right
absolutely you see that speaking out
about anything uh you know if you don't
share the same ideas as somebody yeah
it's like all of a sudden like
no we're gonna force you to be quiet yet
we're going to allow this group over
here to say whatever they want to say
you know
i mean god uses two tools
one of my favorite one of my favorite
guys is his name is ty
and ty gibson says god will draw you to
his heart with love or not at
all which i love but i think
that building on that quote god has two
tools that he uses
love is his attitude and truth is his
modality
so he gives you the facts and he says
i'm love and i'm here
you choose that's it
that's the full stop every other trick
in the toolbox belongs to lucifer
satan bribing intimidation
coercion fear manipulation
deception distraction force trickery
enticement deception like we said
deception
all of those things and and when i think
about traditional in any denomination
traditional evangelism tactics
there's a whole lot of stuff that sounds
like it's out of lucifer's toolbox
i mean but god says here's the facts
and i love you please please choose the
safe path
please choose what is going to be
healthy and whole so that we can spend
eternity together
please pick that it's your call you get
to choose
but just please choose well yeah i want
to
kind of circle back around to something
that nicole was saying
as we're kind of wrapping this up i'm so
thankful that
um really the solution for all of this
is jesus and bringing everybody back to
the cross and that's that's what our
responsibility is we don't have to you
know
yes we need to seek justice not
minimizing that at all but really christ
is the solution for all of it because at
the end of the day
again not not minimizing anybody's pain
or abuse or anything we're all
broken in this world and we all have our
ways
of even little ways the selfish heart we
abuse other people
in in small ways and there are other
people that abuse people in bigger ways
and we all need christ you know we all
need to come to the cross and be healed
and restored and
and jesus came to you know set the
captives free and
essentially we're all captives in this
broken sinful world
and so i'm just thankful that you know
jesus has made a way
that we can be set free and i'm thankful
for the ministry that you
ladies have honestly um you know on this
show
we really feel a passion to to bring up
and talk about subjects that are
difficult to talk about i mean we've
we've handled some pretty crazy things
on this show
um and we're glad that there are people
out there who feel passionate about this
and we're going to be praying for your
guys's ministry um do you want to
tell anyone like any last words if you
guys have
experienced abuse or you you are you
know just watching this for the first
time and recognizing some signs maybe in
your own circles or anything like this
what can they do to find more
information from you guys or like get in
touch
well um nicole and i co-wrote with a
friend of ours
this lovely little book right here
called safe churches responding to abuse
in the faith community and so jennifer
sworzer and nicole and i worked together
on that it's a terrific
training manual and a tool if you are a
leader
in a church of any kind whether that's a
children's ministries leader
a church school teacher a church school
principal
an administrative leader pastor clergy
lay leader
whatever it is this is a great book to
help
you have a better understanding of
forgiveness of identifying perpetrators
of how to act out in policy not act out
in like bad behavior but act out policy
to create things
that will keep your church safer so um
that
the safe churches is on amazon i also
have links to it directly from my
website under books at
wildernesstowild.com
and if you are a woman who is
experiencing
abuse or recovering from abuse or
betrayal trauma
the the excruciating experience of
recognizing that your spouse
has either been unfaithful in real life
or has been acting out on faithfulness
through porn addiction
and so on that um wilde has resources
for you we have we have books thank you
we have books
coaching online courses a lot of
healing post-trauma resources and
there's stuff that's free
there's stuff that you can get involved
with or support groups
and we also have resources where we will
refer you to
other people who have expertise in the
faith community
in various specific niches for certain
types of trauma
so we refer out to a lot of other
colleagues and organizations as well
so that's just wilderness to wild.com
and or
you can follow on facebook i'm just on
facebook
yeah nicole's right follow resources and
by nicole's books
she's not going to say that so i'm going
to say that by nicole's books the tales
of the exodus here
i'm also going to say it because i have
actually read them and they are
excellent books so
great resource i have them linked on my
page too yeah we'll put a link in the
description below but uh
thank you guys for i'm really glad we
could be here
and and i would like to say something to
those who have been victims
of abuse um just realize god is not who
you might feel he is or who your life
circumstances have said he is
god is who he says he is in his word and
i appeal to you to see god in who he
really is in nature if you can't even
read the bible i know sometimes those
who have been through spiritual abuse
just have such a powerful
aversion to the bible see god in what's
around you
and when you can go to the gospels
see god for who he is because he's not
who abusers say he is
and that's when you can love him people
battle and battle to love god i can't
love him i can't love him well that's
because you don't see who he really
is and i just want to say something too
to church leaders
many people are like i'm so thankful for
what you're doing and that's great i
appreciate that
but we're not the shepherds and you can
do an exponential amount of good
by actually taking care of the sheep
rather than leaving that to those of us
who aren't getting paid for it
who don't have enough time for it who
are trying to figure out how to fit in
answering all these victims questions
and helping them in the midst of
making food and taking care of our
children we need
you as church leaders to do what we pay
tithe for you to do
do the justice that god calls you to do
and if you don't know where to start
we've got great resources we're here to
help
we're willing to do anything we can to
make our church into a reflection of the
character of god
the way we want it to be the way god
wants it to be so that we can
together give his picture of his love to
the world
and people can be one to christ please
if you guys like this video share it
with those that you think may need this
information
contact these ladies if you if you want
more information
look up their their ministries or their
facebook pages
and uh thank you guys so much for
watching and uh
just we hope you were blessed by today's
presentation
god bless
[Music]
so
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over 5 million views on
youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
[Music]
i